Speaker 1: A bit of commentary from Trump's
rally in Mendon, Illinois. A mike pillow,
the CEO of Mypillow, Mike Lindell,
known to us as Pillow. Of course.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: He spoke and the crowd essentially
slept through him, saying CNN is no longer
calling it the big lie because it's all
true that the election was stolen from
Trump in 2020. The crowd's totally bored by it.
Speaker 2: CNN gives up getting in front of it.
They said we were no longer call it the big lie
because they know it was the big truth and the
big lie was the big lie.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: So Donald Trump won that
election 81 or 82 million to Biden's
66 million. Those are the real totals, everybody.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Trump really won by what is that,
14, 16, 16 million votes. This is a lie that
they're repeating that CNN no longer calls it
the big lie because it's true that the election
was stolen from Trump. All that happened is that
there's been a shakeup in CNN management and
they've decided they want to get away from
the term the big lie, that nothing is changing
about the truth or in this case, the falsity of
the claim that Joe Biden stole the election from
Trump. They've made an editorial decision not to
call it the big lie. Nothing else has changed.
And also a major, major, major announcement
from Mike Pillow. He is now launching my coffee.
But there's something funny about it which doesn't
sound very patriotic to me. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: But I'm actually going to Miami
in three, three days or four days for
filming. For filming? Tell me we have
my coffee. This is a family owned coffee. Is the
best coffee you ever going to have in your life.
There's nothing like it. I believe me. Everything
that I put out there, I do my due diligence right
now. This has been six months in the world of
work. These guys have their own field in Colombia.
Speaker 1: Whoa, wait a second. They're in
Colombia now. I know many of you will say,
but hold on a second, David. Sir, most coffee
beans are grown outside of the United States.
For climate reasons, the United States is just
not suited. Climatically, climatically, climate.
I think it's climatically to growing coffee
beans. Well, okay, but Hawaii is why isn't
pillow doing the patriotic thing and saying we
will get U.S. raised coffee beans from Hawaii?
No, he's offshoring it to Colombia.
Speaker 2: Family only been doing a it
imagine imagine a micro remember
like a micro pill you know you can
grind your own or you can help you know.
Speaker 1: A micron field what the hell.
Speaker 2: Is already grown? But having that
where you can get it for prices because that's
what I do, bring the best to you, right?
Speaker 1: Well, it sounds like the best
isn't American, Mike. What a what a situation.
And this guy will not go away. It's actually
interesting that he's not fading at all.
And I don't know what to make of it,
but the crowd increasingly bored by Mike Pillow.
We'll take a quick break. Back after this. We
are going to hear some reactions, including
from Kristi Noem, governor of South Dakota,
to a great question. Okay. So you ban abortion.
Who funds all these children that women are
forced to carry the term? She did not have a good
answer. We'll look at it out. Through the break.